dann auch nacken und dann nahm ich ein
schläfer der hatte schon löcher drin und
ein klar und ein sommerkleid waren die
einst müssen klatscht wie ich bin immer
noch sehr gute stück ist ein toller tag
die ganze zeit
[Musik]
du bist im april 1944 bist du abgeholt
worden
von zu hause wie ist es überhaupt dazu
gekommen als achtjähriges kind wurde ich
aufgeweckt in einer in einer nacht im
april und angezogen und und mir wurde
gesagt von meiner mutter blieb zitterte
anziehe und pavel kam und alles zitterte
immer und da war ein mann des wortes das
war bemerkenswert eben für mich als kind
mit zu und russen liedermacher passt und
ganz besser ist an den knöchel heran und
mir wurde gesagt you do
du musst jetzt mit dem amboss 10 und ich
hab versucht seine hand zu nehmen um da
wo ich trank im handy hat mit mit
erwachsenen handschlag
aber der hat meine hand abgelehnt hat
man abend abgelehnt wurde nicht mal an
abend anfassen und dann wurde ich in ein
sammellager gesteckt mit anderen leuten
und in dem von dem sammellager aus
wurden wurde bier transportiert die
gruppe von uns in anzug an viehwagen mit
stroh gedeckt war und nun ein werk über
so 1 1 also drin das war die toilette
und und dann wurden wir transportieren
sehr sehr lange reise sehr sehr lange
reise von von hamburg bis nach auschwitz
in polen
ich hatte kein begriff auschwitz wusste
nicht was los war und habe gedacht als
ich die sterne so habe ich gedacht
als mutter und vater und gerne und ilse
die sind jetzt zu hause und die können
auf dich stellen gleich und sterne sehen
wie ich zu der zeit wusste ich natürlich
nicht dass ich jetzt heim wer ab aber
das ist natürlich das war heimlich hat
er heimweh schon auf dem zug nach
auschwitz ja als ich den abschuss ankam
leute sprang aus erwachsene sprang
daraus und denn dann nahm sie ihre
kinder und texten adolf des waggons
analyst olaf swantee adolf gardt ich war
die letzte die auf den aus den waggons
heraus gegen dennis mit mit meinem
kleinen koffer war ich habe ich mich
habe ich mich nicht gewagt herunter
tisch bringt mit dem koffer in der hand
denn dann so daten mit runden
schäferhunden die schrien uns immer
alles muss schnell schnell raus raus da
hinten nach rechtskraft großer schreien
und hunde bellen und was so alles
und zu guter letzt bin ich runter
gesprungen und meinen kleinen koffer
öffnete sich und meine ganzen sachen
viel heraus und ich drückte mich dann um
die wieder reinzuholen raten anzustecken
und wurde angeschrieben angeschrieben
dass ich dass ich schneller schnell
schnell schnell und eine sinti frau kam
wieder zurück die hat das mitbekommen
dass ich das kind war in in gefahr und
sagte zu mir dass das legen lass das
lege darauf rennen rennen lass das
liegen
und dann habe ich das alles liegt liegen
gelassen mein koffer mit mit mit der
andern unterwäsche und so weiter und so
fort und rannte
und rannte hinter den hinter der kolonne
her oder andere s.oliver köln ab
schilderte wie wahr wie hatte andres
naked ich habe nie an ihm hatten nach
den kriterien bevor in meinem leben und
unsere kleidungsstücken wurde uns gesagt
wird jetzt entlarvt und wir mussten den
einrahmen rahmen den waschraum und wir
mussten uns wasser wurde eingeschaltet
und wir mussten uns durch ihn und als
wir dann raus kam der standen
uniformierte männer zwei uniformierte
männer und die haben uns wenig später
aus findet also als lesung ausgelesen
diddy hat uns wir mussten langsam abend
eben vorbeigehen angst und er guckte uns
alle an und immer nur gezeigt auf die
seite auf die seite auf dieser hatte und
alle die auf diese mussten die waren
alle irgendwie war das nicht richtig
mitnehmen
die keine frau die mich erinnerte die
haben keine zähne und war ziemlich alt
und die hatte ich auch vorher schon
gesehen als auf dem sammellager in
hamburg dass die eine pfeife rauchte und
so weiter und es singt er was man das
war einer der konnte nicht richtig gehen
irgendwie was deshalb verkehrt misst ihn
mit dem mit an bein und so weiter die
ging auf eine seite und wie ich später
erst wesentlich später im leben
herausfanden dass ich ihn irgendwie
sofort
vergast wurden und und und verbrannt
wurde
die sonst sofort das spannt als
todeswunsch und wir wir die anderen die
noch etwas zittern
die wir mussten in die beraten und wir
beraten waren furchtbar
da sich in die partie ging es nämlich
anders so einen tiefen schock kann bin
aus dem ich glaube ich wenn nichts
geschehen wäre welches geschah wer hätte
ich nicht fertig nie wieder
herausgekommen
ich glaube ich werde an mit einem schock
gestorben so tief geschockt war ich aber
eine frau eine sinti frau kam dem
nächsten morgen eine nacht habe ich
übernachtet in der in der baracke ich
bin ab wieviel aufgewachsen
nur mit mit wasser bettwäsche dort gab
es sowas natürlich überhaupt nicht da
gab es nur decken wolldecke nur ob die
konnte man nicht wollte und ist auf
jeden fall decken wo man sich mit so
etwas sollte
die fühlten sich an wie hilfs wie viel
wild ist vielfältig nicht mitträgt
beträgt leiter im land ihr sogar aber
ich habe ein buch gelesen
jemand hat mir das gesagt das ist ein
opfer das war eine sinti sind die kind
die so ein ähnliches schicksal hatte wie
ich das glaube ich
sydney sid
die ist die ist gestorben die ist
gestorben
die hat sich nie wieder aufgerafft aus
dem schock die hat sich nie wieder
ausgepreist ja nicht gegessen und nichts
getrunken er nicht gesprochen und dies
gestorben und die bei onkel mein alter
ich glaube zwei jahre älter als ich 10
oder was und auf jeden fall diese frau
kam zu mir gesagt hat sie mir gesagt
komm mit mir und die das war eine frau
die hatte privileg privileg privilege
ist warum visum ist hab keine ahnung
und die hat den einen kleinen vorbau vor
der baracke einen kleinen vorrat ganz
klein aber das war das wichtigste das
war 100 prozent besser als in der
baracke da war ein bettler in ein tisch
1 1 und ein regal mit mit zwei regalen
das war alles und seltsamerweise ein
eine kleine capello kaputt
kleine teppich was looking
as much much much later habe ich
erfahren dass ein eimer wasser wurde
zugegeben für ein fall für das ganze
lager in dem über 1000 über mehrere
tausend leute gefecht waren 1 war ein
eimer wasser
ich habe mich die ganze zeit so viele ja
aber ich immer gedacht wer wo wo habe
ich jemals wasser gesehen ich habe nie
wasser gesehen
da gab es kein wasser sich zu waschen da
gab es kein wasser zum trinken wir
bekamen café hahn ist braun ist
flüssigkeit wenn einer schüssel es gab
keine teller
das waren blech schüssel aus dem
antreten musste und essen muss aber
nicht zum waschen nicht da gesagt war
kein wasser
du konntest dich dann kommt er sich
nicht waschen da war kein wasser um sich
zu waschen und natürlich dass wir ab
welches ich natürlich alles sie
wissentlich später erfuhr
zu der zeit ich war an kennt ich wusste
nicht was los war
ich erinnere mich an eine holzbaracke
nach holz es kann dabei machte holz
construction wirtschaft welche hatte
eine astra ein astloch astloch und da
hab ich da rein geschaut in das us blog
ich hab immer geguckt was ist das was
ist das es dauert eine ganze weile bevor
ich herausfand dass dies sieht die
eigenartigen umstellung von von arm und
bein waren
und zu guter letzt bekam ich dann als
achtjähriges kind bekam ich das picture
bekam ich die das bild in immer mehr her
das was ich da sah das waren leichen
nackte leichen mit karls überstrahlt
über streut menschen tut mir leid was
wann dann wandert sie müssen wissen was
sie machen dürfen was sie nicht machen
dürfen
sonst sind sie wie tiere jetzt werde ich
gehe ich wieder zurück hat sie als der
aus der dusche kam unsere sachen die
waren entlassen worden
die habe ich mich doch drin energy hat
einen starken chemie kalisch und geruch
und die war aller in ein haufen draußen
auf dem fußboden und alle heckel die
pickel die über und leute mussten
losziehen und witzig ursachen
herausfinden und sich wieder anzuziehen
und musste als achtjähriges kind
ich war so gut aufgezogen worden
ich habe meine eigenen sachen gesucht
ich hab mal eine eigene sache aus diesem
haus und von den kleidungsstücken habe
ich immer gesucht meine was ich an hatte
natürlich was ich an hatte das und sehr
gute kleidungsstücke die waren alle weg
waren und ich hatte ich nicht wie kinder
zu der zeit hatten schlüpfer an und
leibchen sagen was ist das loch noch
heutzutage inbegriffen leibchen mit mit
zu spendern wo kinder
ihre strümpfe mit abhielten gibt dass
das heute noch gibt es nicht zu der zeit
gab es das ganze gute schuhe rock bluse
eine strickjacke
das hatte ich das konnte ich alles nicht
finden und zu guter letzt als er
ungefähr noch 456 sachen affen fußboden
lagen hat eine frau an es sind die frau
bemerkt gehängt dass ich an kind alleine
bin und hat zu mir gesagt du musst
irgendwas nehmen
du hast noch nichts an ich war immer
noch bestand immer noch nacken da
gestern nichts sagen du musst schon fast
etwas anziehen
ich sage ich kam hab gesagt ich kann
meine sachen nicht finden neben
irgendwas nehmen was und dann nahm ich
ein schnitzer der hatte schon löcher
drin
ich nehme an dass dass er das war der
grund dass er nicht nicht genommen wurde
an schlüpfer mit löchern
den habe ich genommen habe ich genommen
und ein klarheit ein sommerkleid cotton
baumwolle mit kurzem und welches
ungefähr passte ungefähr
und das war alles das war alles nicht so
gar nichts mehr und nichts mehr keine
strümpfe keine schuhe nichts dass wir
alle die zweite platz war klar um stücke
waren die einst müssen klatscht wie ich
bin immer noch sehr guten stück ist ein
sonntag
die ganze zeit konnte trotz daneben kann
ich es natürlich heutzutage bündeln
niemand erwartet dass es jetzt über
solche schlachten zu schlagen ist es
trocken schlucken und ungestört über die
schlaglöcher große schlaglöcher in der
schweiz im alpen
in hamburg auf der wings ihn laut poster
mit schalke was sie will vororten über
wien interessiert ihn
ich bin nie interessiert gewesen an
politik politiques und so weiter hab ich
an großen poster gesehen in england über
wie die situation in südafrika aussieht
mit der apartheid und der pudel alles
gelistet was die die ducks nicht durften
was die nicht liegen dürften sich nicht
auf der banken setzen welche für für
weiße machen und zum alter und sofort
und so weiter und so fort
und wenn ich das alles lars damit einmal
ging mir ein licht im kopf ab ich wurde
genauso behandelt ich wurde immer
schlechter behandelt als schwarze in
südafrika und als das das licht aufgehen
in meinem kopf damit einmal kann kam die
ganze sache
die ganze sache alles was mir geschah es
dass das geschehen war
ex-playmate lade ich nehme an ich hatte
es bringt ja
auf dem berg 1 3 in klein klein kein und
im training vor mein mann noch x mal
nicht man riecht man mutter man immer
etliche mutter meine mutter schickte ich
wo ich aufwuchs kreide
der ki.ka hat man den arsch 19
ordensburg missbrauchen es viel später
als die heraus das kam erst viel später
erst partie
aber dein vater bei dem du aufgewachsen
ist hatte ich nicht vergessen in der
zeit nein der hat alles getan um wieder
zu sehen was hat er getan
fast zuerst ist es siegten kriminal
briten gegangen in hamburg und hat sich
beschwert dass ihm nicht gesagt worden
dass da irgendwas imam imam hintergrund
nicht stimmte zu der zeit als als er das
kind an die tierliebe street bradley im
angst allerdings morgens 7 uhr wird noch
an noch ein wort von ihnen unter band
lasse ich sie auf warften denn schon in
35 in dem jahr als nämlich geboren waren
schon gesetze herausgekommen indem es
verboten war
für deutsche beziehung zu haben mit mit
leuten welche rassisch nicht arisch
waren ungarischen leuten visionen und
sind dies in römershag mein vater
gemacht hat war natürlich gefährlich ist
er hatte sich seine eigene familie er
selbst und seine familie hatte darunter
leiden können dass er sich für ein
setzte dafür für sagen zunahme seine
tochter welche er immer sagt der wirt
meine tochter meine tochter das war ist
aus eine tochter wurde wurde weckt in
uns und das ist nicht richtig dies
können sie doch nicht machen und so
weiter gucken sie sich doch die fotos an
von dem kind das sie dort sieht die aus
wie arisch ist kind und so weiter
die sah nicht aus wie ein ungarisches
kind die war blond und blauäugig aber
wie gesagt das war alles das hat alles
nicht hin
und dann hat er angefangen briefe zu
schreiben hat sogar an hitler
geschrieben an göring an alle die im
iran himmler und zu guter letzt hat er
einen plan bekommen von martin bohmann
martin bohn und ich glaube ich habe
glaube ich bin ziemlich sicher dass
martin bohmann war der sekretär von
hitler
das musste so hochgehen ist zu martin
boomen bevor jemand die die society
hatte um das zu veranlassen dass jemand
aus an konzentrationslager entlassen
wurde
auf jeden fall mein vater hat das hat
das geschafft
und er hatte das den entlassung scheint
und dann ist er losgezogen und hat mich
abgeholt von ravensbrück denn in der
zwischenzeit war ich es erlebt von
auschwitz nach ahrensburg
wie stark waren die unterschiede
zwischen auschwitz dem vernichtungslager
und dann ravensbrück natürlich ich war
alleine ich hatte natürlich man immer
noch nicht bei mir und ich hatte carl
ich war wieder in einer baracke aber die
baracke war nicht so schlimm wie den
arsch aber es war schlecht für mich
persönlich dadurch dass ich wandern
nicht hatte und dass ich nicht die
protection vom wandern denn in das das
erste mal in ravensbrück dass ich
geschlagen wurde von anna nazi frau mit
einer peitsche
das war das erste mal dass hätten die
schweiz hätten sich das nicht gemacht da
ich ja und da man das geschützt war
er warum würdest du geschlagen publikum
die wir waren in unserer paten und da
kam eine eine helferin die war keine die
hatte keine uniform an aber die hier mit
hier half den den uniformierten leuten
und sagte komm rein und es ist eher ein
niesen hier alle raus alles raus ich
habe mich aufgerafft und bin aus manacor
herausgeklettert ich war auf der dritten
etage kuncic 11 23 da muss aber auf
klettern und da geklettert und bin nach
außen gegangen ich war aber nur die
einzigste die nach außen gegen alle die
anderen die haben sich doch gar nicht
darum gekümmert was die frau gesagt
hatte und als ich da heraus kam da kam
eine frage uniformierte frauen mit der
peitsche und fragte mich doch was machen
was machst du denn was was du hier
draußen was machst du dir ich habe
antwort gegeben ich habe gesagt wir
wurden wir wurden gesagt wir müssen
andere haus und dass das hat sie so
geärgert dass ich dass ich den mut hatte
sie etwas zu sagen da hat sie mich mit
der peitsche auf die affäre um die panik
gehabt fühlt es sich an als wenn feuer
um dann geht eine lange zeit fühlte sich
an wie wirken sich feuer und eine art
eine schwingt ja wenn da was hängen das
ist ein kind nicht versteht ein als auch
die raus die anderen auch was jetzt wie
lange was du in ravensbrück male liest
frauen ravensbrück bis ende september
special items in ravensburg
ja wenn ich im kollektiv ravensburg er
kam um nicht aktionen wie hast du
dadurch erfahren wie hast du erfahren
dass das duo frei kommt also immer
gucken mal crew im dritten stock und in
der mitteldistanz nach mitteldistanz das
tasting mitteldistanz nach zombie live
loslässt
ich saß ich stehe ja und ich würde sie
ihren mund immer auf und zu gehen dass
sie was achte aber nicht gehört nicht
war schon so weit weg gewand kommt nicht
zugehört was sie sagt und dann zu guter
letzt ging es in meinem kopf dass sie
immer meinen arm schreihälse schnell
sich else schmidt und runter geklettert
sie hingegangen
komm mit mir du wirst entlassen und dann
musste ich mich wieder duschen wieder
duschen dann mein gott ich habe jetzt
sechs monate habe ich ja aber ich kann
habe ich nie wasser gehabt und nicht zu
machen ich habe ihn nie seife auch wenn
ich selbst gehabt hatte er hatte mir das
nichts genützt ich hatte kein wasser
niemand hatte was er da
deswegen starten sie alle abtei von
gartner
ich habe natürlich kann man darin krätze
erforschung und du triffst immer noch
das gleiche wie in auschwitz
ppps nichols und unterhosen unterhose
mit löchern durchlöchert auf jeden fall
und dann wurde ich eine große zahl
geleitet und da waren alle tische belegt
mit kleidungsstücken unterwäsche
strümpfe schuhe kleider hosen röcke
blusen menschen und so weiter und so
weiter und so fort
und dann hat sie zu mir gesagt dusche
und dann neben der zieh dich an aus
sachen aus hier aus dass diesem rahmen
und ich war so verstört dass ich
geduscht habe kann mich aber nicht daran
erinnern ob ich in der hand hatte und
bin in den raum gegangen und habe nur
dagestanden habt nicht nicht geworden
ist etwas anzufassen
denn ich ich hat war unter dem eindruck
wenn mir was gesagt wurde das ist nicht
richtig
die hatte gesagt geh raus das war nicht
sie dachte ich sage mir was aussuchen
ihr das mal
es ist wahrscheinlich nicht richtig ist
wahrscheinlich gefährlich dass sie
gefährlich standen über stand da gehörst
du deine haare noch eigentlich oder
haben die abrasiert
gegen sinti und roma star wurden nicht
abgeschnitten dass die über nicht
abgeschnitten
das amt habe ich nur die zehn und ideen
yukos wurden
denn das endlager war etwas anders als
die juden lage zu der zeit ist mir schon
aufgefallen als kind ist mir schon
aufgefallen
das jugendlager war auf einer seite von
uns auf einer seite nur abgetrennt mit
diesen electric der glätte rivalität
er hat juni vor
und streift junior suite und es kam zu
mir und hat gesehen was los war dass ich
dass ich angst hatte etwas zu machen und
hat mir was ausgesucht hat mir selber
was ausgesucht und habe mir etwas
gegeben zum zum zum anziehen und dann
musste ich ins büro musste ich mich
dahin setzen wurde
setz dich hin dein vater kommt und da
kam dann auch und da mussten wir auf zu
dem schreibtisch hin und wir mussten
unterscheiden ich sogar fast als
achtjähriges kind
ich musste unterschreiben mit meiner
kinder handschrift es ist schön dass ich
nicht was was wo ich gewesen war und
sogar überhaupt nicht darüber sprechen
und hast du dann in dem büro wo du das
unterschrieben hast hast du deinen vater
wiedergetroffen ich war zu verstört um
in seine arme zu laufen oder was weiß
ich war viel zerstört viel zu verstört
ich war zu obamas dem schockierten thoma
ich war traumata ist der ton den cayenne
in motion vielleicht letzten später hat
mein vater gesagt als wir beantragten
dass das meine mutter für tot erklärt
werden man eine richtige mutter für tot
erklärt wird mussten wir irgendwohin
in hamburg zu einer behörde und er
musste test erfahren wie das alles lief
mit mehr und so weiter und so fort und
unter anderem sagt er dass sein sein
kind war wie eine wir eine sein kind
erschien ihm die alten haben zurück wie
eine mumie und movistar
hast du die nähe zu deinen eltern
irgendwann wieder gefunden
dann fanden radtour hat dann viel kampf
dagegen von rendsburg seid ihr nach nach
hause gefahren mit dem zug und oder ja
mein vater hat sogar hier römer zu da
hat sogar erster klasse gebucht erster
klasse denn er war unter dem eindruck
dass ich vielleicht nicht in einer guten
verfassung zu gehen hat sogar und der
war das von einfache leute die haben
nicht viel geld verdient dass man arbeit
hat aber trotzdem hat er sich aufgerafft
und das geld gefunden für erste klasse
erster klasse wie war das nach hause zu
kommen
ich war ziemlich verstört und das mich
daran zu erinnern wie alle eine mumie
dann vergällt wie ging es danach weiter
ist ja nicht einfach am nächsten tag in
die schule gegangen in der nächsten
woche gegen ich wieder zur schule
in der schule wurde ich von einem lehrer
der hat in mein pflaster auf dem das
tätowiert die tätowierung die ich auf
meinem arm hatte sondern als auschwitz
über die überlegende
ein kleines pflaster dazu er hat mich
auf die gefragt dass ich mich für die
klassenkasse hinstellen soll und den und
ihm sagen soll was unterm arm ein
pflaster ist trotzdem ich musste
unterschreiben dass ich nicht darüber
sprechen was mir geschah in asch witz
und ich hab ich bin erstarrt und habe
nichts gesagt habe nur dazu gestanden
und event nach einer zeit hat er wohl
gemerkt dass ich total zerstört denn und
hat mich ich durfte mich wieder
hinsetzen
wir haben die kinder die anderen kindern
an die kinder haben sich überhaupt nicht
darum kümmern
ich nehme abend die haben jetzt mit dem
pflaster überhaupt nicht gemerkt das
waren nur der die erwachsenen sie sind
in diesem falle in dieser lehrer hat es
gemacht welches natürlich sehr
unangenehm für mich war sehr unangenehm
ja was hast du mit deinen eltern und
geschwistern geredet der haben mich
nicht ab 8 nachgefragt nur mein vater
hat mich danach kurz rat hat mich aber
immer ins schlafzimmer genommen um mit
mir alleine zu sprechen
und er hat mich gefragt was wie die
sache da liegt was ging nach los und ich
habe ihnen gesagt habe und der wurden
leute lebendig verbrannt welches war
vielleicht günstig dass das man ist
seine frau das nicht hörte und jetzt als
zehn seine gesichtsmuskeln und das ist
immer so
das ist ein anderes ding welt wo alles
sehr daran erinnere ist nur ein kind ist
es ihr eigenartig hatte noch nie mal man
meinen vater gesehen mit mit muskeln im
gesicht zu gucken was da hatte ich noch
nie gesehen
ich nehme an es war sehr emotional das
ist sehr emotional war dass solche
sachen zu hören
kindermund hast du ihm noch mehr erzählt
hast du ihm alles erzählt was ihr aber
hab ich bewahren der hat ihm zum wandern
erzählt spannende mich und was man am
meer erzählt hatte
wann da hat mich sogar als er hat mich
aufgefordert an brief zu schreiben wurde
überlegt sie hatten sie hat die hat es
geschafft hat papier zu bekommen und
bleistift und umschlag ja man da hatte
das und ich mussten sie sie sagte
schreiten brief und ich konnte mich als
achter ihn natürlich noch an meine
eigene adresse erinnern
und da wurde abgeschickt und ich sag sie
hat mir diktiert was ich sagen soll
ich bin ich bin jetzt alles ist okay
hier mama und kannst aber ich könnte mir
bitte eine strickjacke schicken und
sagen und und was weiß ich und und da
ist der brief ist angekommen
der brief ist angekommen aus auschwitz
auschwitz an brief karmann in osdorf und
die haben ein paket gepackt welches mit
welch ist welches ich bekam hat sich
schon im rahmen zurück war alles heraus
nur einige gebrochene gebrochene kekse
man da noch drin und ein gehäkeltes
taschentuch behälter dem man sich als
kind um den hals hängt und mit dem
kleinen ding da dran wo du dann
taschentuch drin herbst ein taschentuch
hat sagt er denn auf eine platine
taschentuch und zahnd hass und zahnpasta
drehen zahnpasta platin herrn dass kein
wasser zum zum dichter daneben nimmt
dann hindern zu waschen oder dein
gesicht zu waschen
lettland branchen your platini
ja die arnie aus japan und in
strickjacke kinder hat bat eine
pasta-party hat das simpson-team
biscuits daraus oder moslem wie hast du
das kriegsende im frühjahr 1945 in
hamburg liegt eine freundin von mir
sagte zu mir dass ich glaube ihr habt
ihr gedacht wir werden den krieg
verlieren und sie sagten ein tier werden
den krieg nicht verlieren denn wir haben
eine spezial waffe als nun ihre
gesprochen wird
ob wir den krieg gewinn mit mit der
spezial waffe und wir haben den krieg
nicht gewonnen und die engländer die
engländer sind eingezogen
und da habe ich trotzdem dem
ausgangsverbot habe ich bin ich auf den
auf dem baum geklettert ganz hoch in die
in die höhe
dabei musste mindestens 400 jahre alt
sein
sehr sehr große bäume und ich hab ich
habe die die autos langen kolonnen von
autos den englischen autors gesehen als
sie zu der kaserne fuhren in die finger
jaja abschließend bisher quasi ein
mensch der der d3 identitäten haben
könnte alles was fühlst du dich gut
christen gute frage ich wüsste ich ich
wäre froh wenn ich die gut beantworten
könnte leider kann ich das nicht das
erste was ich dazu sagen kann als ich
einmal
in hamburg jugendlich mit jugendlichen
sprach über meine erlebnisse und unter
anderem in den jugendlichen war auch
eine sinti dann sind die junge dame
ungefähr 17 jahre oder 18 jahre alten
aber ungefähr und eine fragte mich was
ist ihre identität und ich hab meine
antwort war ich kann ihn das nicht
beantworten ich bin nicht ich bin nicht
sicher was man denn thet ist und dann
unterbrach die sind die junge dame und
sagte sie gehört zu uns und da war ich
froh drüber als ich das hörte da habe
ich mich darüber gefreut aber ich hab
gedacht warum darf jeden fall ist eine
person eine person denkt ich bin der
identität ich sehr froh darüber denn und
darf nicht vergessen dass erst in 48 war
wurde mir deutsche staatsangehörigkeit
zugesprochen
aber die art deutsche
staatsangehörigkeit so spät im leben zu
bekommen
man ist sich nicht sicher ist man
richtig deutsch ist man richtig deutsch
ist man richtig 100 prozent deutsch ist
man isst man sinti und roma ist man
sinti und roma nie mit sinti und roma
zusammengelebt auf jeden fall bin ich
nicht englisch vielleicht würde ich wenn
ich gezwungen würde würde ich lasse mich
bezeichnen als eine deutsche sinti und
roma frau
bern wurde dass dichter ganz ganz ganz
ganz wenigen wirklich mehr als wir uns
erhofft und versprochen haben vielen
dank dafür
okay da war nicht viel möglich nein